.
KATE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT THIS
SEARCH AND HOPEFULLY RESCUE.
JOINING US RIGHT NOW IS OCEAN
EXPLORER TOM DETWILER, HE LED
THE TEAM THAT FOUND THE WRECKAGE
OF THE TITANIC, IS ALSO A CLOSE
FRIEND WITH PH NARGEOLET ONE OF
THE PEOPLE ON BOARD THE MISSING
VESSEL.
WHAT ARE YOUR NEW THOUGHTS ON
THIS REPORTING THAT WE WERE TALK
BEING WITH MIGUEL MARQUEZ OF
SEARCH CREWS PICKING UP REPEATED
BANGING SOUNDS VIA SONAR
DEVICES.
DOES THAT GIVE YOU HOPE?
>> WELL, LIKE EVERYBODY, YOU
WANT TO HOLD OUT HOPE UNTIL
THERE CAN BE NO MORE HOPE.
THE BANGING SOUNDS ARE
INTERESTING BECAUSE KNOWING PH
NARGEOLET AND HIS EXPERIENCE
WITH SUBMERSIBLES AND HIS
BACKGROUND IN SUBMARINES THIS IS
EXACTLY HOW HE WOULD TRY TO
INDICATE THAT THEY WERE STILL
ALIVE AND TRY TO COMMUNICATE
WITH SURFACE.
HE WOULD DO SOME BANGING, DO IT
ON A NEG LAR SCHEDULE SO THAT IT
WAS DISHABLE FROM THE BACKGROUND
NOISES THAT ARE IN THE OCEAN ALL
THE TIME.
SO IT IS ENCOURAGING THAT THERE
DID SEEM TO BE A PATTERN TO IT
AND, YOU KNOW, WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HOLD OUT HOPE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
TOM, IS THAT -- DO YOU THINK
THAT THAT WOULD BE -- YOU SAID
THAT WOULD BE EXACTLY WHAT HE
WOULD BE DOING.
IS THAT, DO YOU THINK, PH WOULD
BE IMPROVISING OR IS THIS SOME
SORT OF, I DON'T KNOW, STANDARD
PROTOCOL OR PROCEDURE THAT
YOU'RE FAMILIAR OF WHEN IT COMES
TO UNDERWATER EMERGENCIES?
>> IT IS A STANDARD PROTOCOL FOR
CONTACTING ANY SORT OF RESCUE
SERVICE THAT MIGHT BE COMING
YOUR WAY.
>> THAT IS SUPER INTERESTING.
YOU'VE DESCRIBED PH AS A
CLOSE -- AS A CLOSE FRIEND.
I WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU, TOM,
WHAT ANOTHER OCEAN EXPLORER
DAVID GALLO SAID ABOUT P.H. ON
CNN LAST NIGHT.
LET ME PLAY THIS FOR YOU.
>> IF P.H. NARGEOLET WAS SITTING
HERE WITH ME LIKE HE NORMALLY
WOULD BE, THIS IS WHAT HE WOULD
SAY TO DO, LET'S JUST SIT DOWN
TOGETHER IN A SMALL ROOM, FIGURE
OUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AND
LET'S MAKE IT HAPPEN, LET'S DO
IT.
>> TOM, WHAT DO YOU THINK P.H.
WOULD BE SAYING RIGHT NOW?
>> IT WOULD BE EXACTLY THAT.
HE IS VERY CALM, COLLECTED,
EXPERT IN HIS FIELD AND, YOU
KNOW, WE WOULD HAVE APPROACHED
THIS IN A VERY SCIENTIFIC
MANNER, VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD
MANNER AND JUST GET THE FASTEST
REACTION OUT THERE THAT WE COULD
HAVE.
I'VE SPENT THE LAST TWO DAYS
TRYING TO GET AN EFFORT OUT
THERE, IT'S ON ITS WEIWEI NOW
AND I KNOW THAT P.H. WOULD HAVE
DONE THE SAME THING FOR ANYBODY
ELSE OUT THERE, WHETHER HE KNEW
THEM OR NOT.
THE COMMUNITY WOULD HAVE DRAWN
TOGETHER JUST LIKE YOU'VE SEEN
IT OVER THE LAST COUPLE DAYS AND
WE WOULD DO ANYTHING IN OUR
POWER TO GET OUT THERE.
NEVER QUESTIONING COSTS, NEVER
QUESTIONING TIME, YOU KNOW, JUST
DO IT.
DROP EVERYTHING.
>> TOM, TALK TO ME ABOUT THE
EFFORT AND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
GET OUT THERE AND WHAT YOU'VE
SEEN THAT'S BEEN DEPLOYED SO
FAR.
TALK TO ME ABOUT THE SCOPE AND
SCALE AND WHAT THEY'RE ALSO UP
AGAINST IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
FIND THEM AND GET TO THEM.
>> WELL, SOME OF THE EXPERTS
HAVE ALREADY SAID THAT, YOU
KNOW, YOU SEE NAVY ASSETS GOING
OUT THERE, THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE NAVY ASSETS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ON THEIR WAY ARE THE
ASSETS THAT ARE EXPERIENCED IN
FINDING THINGS UNDER WATER AND
DOING RECOVERIES FROM VERY
DEEPWATER.
SOME OF THE FEW ASSETS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AND THEY WILL GET
THERE WITHIN THE NEXT DAY OR SO.
THAT'S THE LIMITATION IS IT'S
VERY FAR OUT THERE AND, YOU
KNOW, JUST GETTING THIS VERY
HEAVY EQUIPMENT MOVING, GET IT
TO WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE,
MOBILIZING IT ON THE SHIP, AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE, WHEN A SHIP
GOES OUT TO SEA EVERYTHING HAS
TO BE FASTENED DOWN SO YOU'RE
DOING A LOT OF WELDING AND
THINGS LIKE THAT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT STAYS IN PLACE AS THE
SHIP STARTS TO ROLL IN THE SEAS,
AND THEN, YOU KNOW, IT HAS TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE THE LOAD IF YOU'RE
DOING A RECOVERY.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT
HAS TO BE DONE, BUT THESE ARE
ALL GUYS WHO DO THIS ROUTINELY
AND THEY DO IT QUICKLY AND I
THINK THAT YOU WILL SEE SOME
SUCCESS IN FINDING IT QUICKLY.
>> WHERE IS YOUR HEART AND HEAD
ON THIS RIGHT NOW?
I KNOW YOU SAID THAT YOU WANT TO
HOLD OUT HOPE BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT
TO HOLD OUT HOPE FOR ANOTHER
DAY, YOU ALSO KNOW THE REALITIES
OF THE RISKS AND THE DANGERS
DOWN THERE.
I MEAN, YOU'VE -- YOU PROBABLY
KNOW IT BETTER THAN ANYBODY.
>> MY WHOLE CAREER HAS BEEN IN
THE VERY DEEP OCEAN AND I DO
KNOW ALL THE THINGS THAT CAN
HAPPEN AND I'VE RUN OVER ALL
THOSE IN MY HEAD.
BUT I'VE SEEN MIRACLES HAPPEN AT
SEA AS WELL, VERY UNEXPECTED
THINGS, VERY SURPRISING THINGS.
SO I'M GOING TO CONTINUE TO HOLD
OUT HOPE.
THEY STILL HAVE SOME OXYGEN LEFT
AND YOU HAVE TO CONSIDER THAT
THE OXYGEN ESTIMATES ARE BASED
ON NORMAL ACTIVITIES IN THE SUB.
ONE THING P.H. WOULD HAVE DONE
IS TRIED TO CALM EVERYBODY DOWN
AND KEEP THEM QUIET SO THAT
THEY'RE USING LESS OXYGEN.
YOU CAN POTENTIALLY EXTEND THAT
BEYOND THE ESTIMATES.
>> TOM, I CAN'T -- THAT'S SUPER
IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER IN ALL OF
THIS AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON, HAVING YOUR LEVEL OF
EXPERTISE AND ALSO JUST TO HEAR
ABOUT YOUR FRIENDSHIP WITH P.H.
AND WHAT YOU KNOW HE WOULD BE
DOING DOWN THERE RIGHT NOW IS
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, TOM.
>> YOU'RE QUITE WELCOME, KATE.
>> JOHN?
>> THAT WAS A GREAT DISCUSSION.
>>> THIS MORNING WE HAVE A
FIRSTHAND ACCOUNT OF WHAT IT IS
LIKE TO TAKE PART IN THIS KIND
OF UNDERWATER ADVENTURE.
ONE YEAR AGO SIMPSON'S WRITER
MIKE REESE WAS ON THE SAME
SUBMERSIBLE THAT IS MISSING IN
THE ATLANTIC.
HE TOLD A CNN AFFILIATE ABOUT
THE DANGERS HE PROO PREPARED FOR
AHEAD OF THE TRIP AND EXPLAINED
THE NAVIGATIONAL ISSUES HIS TEAM
EXPERIENCED DURING THE DIVE.
>> IT WAS JUST 11 MONTHS AGO IN
THIS VERY SAME SUB AND I SEE
OVER AND OVER ON EVERY DIVE WE
TOOK THEY LOST COMMUNICATION.
THIS IS JUST ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
WITH THIS THING.
YOU KNOW, I'M SURE THE WORLD IS
VERY WORRIED AND THAT KIND OF
THING, BUT SOMETHING TO KNOW
HAVING GONE THROUGH IT IS YOU
KNOW GOING IN HOW VERY DANGEROUS
THIS IS.
IT'S NOT ANY BAD REFLECTION
ON -- ON STOCKTON RUSH, IT'S HIS
COMPANY AND HE DESIGNED IT, BUT
IT'S JUST THAT WE ARE ALL PART
OF THIS ONGOING EXPERIMENT.
BEFORE YOU EVEN GET ON YOU SIGN
THIS LONG, LONG WAIVER THAT
MENTIONS POSSIBLE DEATH THREE
TIMES ON THE FIRST PAGE.
SO YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GETTING
INTO.
IN FACT, WHEN I STEPPED ON TO
THE SUB I JUST -- YOU KNOW, PART
OF MY MIND WAS GOING, WELL, THIS
COULD BE THE END.
>> WOW.
>> SO THAT -- I MEAN, MOSTLY,
YOU KNOW, IT'S A VERY CREEPY
FEELING TO THINK IF THEY'RE
ALIVE, DOWN AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
OCEAN OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
AND, YOU KNOW, JUST KNOWING I
DON'T THINK THERE IS A WAY TO
GET THEM OUT OF THE SITUATION
LIKE THAT AND THAT THEY WILL
JUST BE SITTING THERE FOR THREE
OR FOUR DAYS BEFORE THE OXYGEN
RUNS OUT, VERY SCARY THOUGHT.
>> SCARY INDEED.
I DID NOTE, SARA, HE SAID THAT
EVERY DIVE THEY TOOK THEY LOST
COMMUNICATION.